So the haka, to me, it means a part of my cultural identity.
It is a part of my customs, my traditions.
And it was an important ceremonial dance...
...that was passed down from my ancestors and we still practice it today.
This is what I love.
I love being able to show my culture off to the world.
It's the only job in the world...
...where you get to poke your tongue out at your customers...
...and you get paid for it.
Yeah, that's a good reason to do it, right?
Very, very proud, actually, to be able to show our culture to the world...
...and people like yourself embrace it.
Yeah.
They embrace our culture and they love it.
And do you think you can do this your entire life?
I'll keep on doing it as long as I can.
As long as I can stomp my feet and do the haka.
My grandparents were a part of that forbidden generation...
...that weren't allowed to speak the language.
And that came down to ignorance from the non-Maori...
...that were around at the time...
...who felt threatened by the language...
...because they couldn't understand what our people were saying.
They tried to outlaw.
In fact, they did.
They passed a law that forbid Maori to speak their native tongue...
...and if they did speak the native tongue...
...they were strapped for speaking the language.
Because of that ignorance,...
...it caused the whole language to miss an entire generation,...
...which was my parents' generation.
But in the past, I'd say past 20 years,...
...a lot of work has been done to revive "Te Reo."
We've got universities now providing Maori language courses...
...to help with the revival of "Te Reo" Maori.